good morning Hank it's Tuesday VidCon is
this week in a related story oh is the
sound that my anxiety makes so Hank I'm
in a hotel in Canada at a conference
about educational video featuring like
CGP grey and Vsauce and minutephysics
and vy are tons of fascinating people
but Hank the operative word there is
Canada because as you remember from the
last time that we went to Canada it is
not easy for me to get into Canada right
so this happens every time I come to
Canada but I fly in I have my customs
forms filled out I get in line and then
I am sent at like this special
immigration office for felons and other
undesirables and then I am asked if I
have ever been denied entrance to Canada
before and I say yes
in 1995 I was denied entrance to your
fine country due to insufficient funds
so Hank this was in the halcyon days
before teenagers had credit cards and
when I was a freshman in college a
friend of mine and I we drove up to
Windsor Ontario it's a friend of mine
and I are a friend of mine and me a
friend of mine and I I was right to
begin with I just trust my instincts so
we drove to Windsor with a two liter
bottle of Mountain Dew a loaf of bread
and some peanut butter and $14 I don't
know by what definition that constitutes
insufficient funds
so we tried across the border they
searched our car for drugs then they
turn us around for insufficient funds we
go back to America where they again
search our car for drugs this time for
three hours even though we never got to
Canada but it was fine we had a nice
story when we got back to college we
were too poor for Canada I think I never
had a problem getting into Canada until
2001 when suddenly my name appeared on a
list of undesirables and now every
single time I go to Canada I am forced
to explain again that in 1995 I was
deemed insufficiently wealthy to visit
this great nation oh and then they
searched my bags and let me go on my way
so anyway today I asked the guy is this
gonna last forever is there any way I
can clear my name make a donation to
your health care system or something
that will allow me to not be on the list
and he said and I'm quoting him directly
here Hank mr. green you're gonna die on
that list so that's my story of how I
became undesirable to Canadians
Canadians perhaps this helps you
understand why I
tor here more often also nerdfighters if
history tells us anything it's that Hank
will fail to upload his video on Friday
due to VidCon stress so prepare your
punishment ideas and leave them in
comments
this ain't comments or comments I really
don't enunciate very well for an
ostensibly professional video blogger